okay politics again
all right we literally just had an
election listen brother i just hate each
side equally being apolitical is a
lifestyle it means i don't have to
analyze any of my inherent beliefs and i
can just let society mold me as it
pleases of course poor people are bad
jerry seinfeld hey do you want a side
phone just makes me mad when people
can't accept everyone's political
opinions even though they inherently
contradict each other i'm gonna be
honest brother i have some super
problematic friends and just saying that
we're apolitical seems to make people
less mad at us war is inherently cool
like that's not a political statement
i'm not gonna lie guys it's hard hard
out there for us a political people our
apathy is attacked on all sides i'm
scared of having opinions like do you
know what people do to you online when
you have opinions that shit's scary man
sometimes it can be so hard to be
spineless politics used to be so much
better when i was like five years old